i gotta say this is absolutely uh one of
the nicest moments of my life
it has been forever since we've seen an
audience
god bless you for being here thank you
so much
thank you
we have a live crowd this is insane
it's it's i mean they have masks on so
we hope they're smiling
yeah yeah i i feel terrible you all
i guess we're waiting in line for 15
months outside the field
i would drive by every day and just see
them like he'll be back
i've got a pop doll that needs signing
i see you and i'll get to you yes
i have to say that is the one constant
even through the pandemic
people like in hazmat suits coming up to
me with pop dolls
sign the pop doll
[Laughter]
use a robotic arm
must sell on ebay uh
or keep i'm sure you'll treasure it
forever it's not even the doll it's the
box if you take it out of the box it's
ruined
this is very uh
i don't even remember what you look like
uh
i have to say
ben i even i even put on long pants you
were on long pants i know
because i was sitting back there and
nobody could see from the waist down i
know i know i usually had a nice
a smart skirt yeah yeah
anywho
i can't believe this though we have
eight more shows left
and then i am moving on to fight logan
paul
[Applause]
conan put your hands in front of your
face
a long time ago it started out live i
wanted to do a character it's a guy
who's very religious and he's a boxer
and his one flaw he's as great as he
always has to cross himself before he
throws a punch
and he gets killed every time he's like
that's why i had to get out of the
writing game anyway
i just want to remind everyone at home
andy you referenced it but our audience
is wearing masks tonight
we're trying to comply so if you hear
anything less than raucous laughter
it's the masks everything that was a
huge laugh i got right there no no
huge one of the biggest of my career but
it had to fight its way through
cotton gods